[Música]
y para nosotras llega el momento de
hablar con nuestro segundo invitado del
día y le planteamos la situación que
vivió Colombia Cuando dio un suspiro de
alivio y de alegría cuando los cuatro
menores desaparecidos en la selva tras
un accidente de avioneta el pasado 1 de
Mayo fueron encontrados después de
sobrevivir 40 días a su suerte y según
anunció el mismo presidente Gustavo
Petro los menores están ahora fuera de
peligro y se recuperan en el hospital
Militar de Bogotá donde llegaron
deshidratados y con a problemas de
nutrición sin embargo lo que preocupa
ahora es el futuro para estos niños en
el corto y en el medio plazo y para
hablar sobre esta cuestión tenemos la
suerte de contar con Luis Acosta El ex
coordinador Nacional de la guardia
indígena Luisa Muchísimas gracias por
estar con nosotros en France 24 un
saludo de armonía de los pueblos
indígenas de Colombia aquí con una
alegría total en mi serie en mi espíritu
por haber hecho parte de esta búsqueda
esta operación esperanza de los pueblos
indígenas en coordinación con el
ejército de Colombia una coordinación
entre la sabiduría ancestral de los
pueblos y y el conocimiento tecnológico
de las fuerzas militares y este
conocimiento ancestral que usted
menciona Luis ha sido crucial tanto para
encontrar a estos menores no como
también para la supervivencia de ellos
cuatro liderados por la mayor no por
Leslie usted nos lo comentaba hace un
momento concretamente este conocimiento
ancestral en que se tradujo durante sus
40 días de supervivencia creo que el
saber ancestral de los pueblos que
tienen todos los pueblos en el mundo y
en este caso los pueblos indígenas de la
amazonía sus sistemas de conocimiento
ancestrales que se trascienden y que se
dan de generación en generación nuestros
abuelos nos enseñan nosotros aprendemos
alrededor del fogón alrededor de en la
casa es por eso que si aprende sobre la
selva se conoce sobre la selva y Leslie
tenía claro eso y por eso ella no se
asusta como en una declaración que le
comenta dice no me asusto signo que
logro entender lo que estoy viviendo
otro niño de otra latitud no no hubiera
sobrevivido sobrevivido por la capacidad
y por el conocimiento que tenía Leslie
sobre la selva sobre los riesgos de la
selva sobre la selva y sobre ese
conocimiento que sea en la casa de cómo
cómo entender y conocer la selva creo
que es fundamental ese conocimiento que
se da en las familias que sea en las
casas y también el saber ancestral y por
eso solicitó el presidente a la guardia
indígena nacional a las guardias
indígenas de la región guardias
indígenas de esa región amazónica de
caquetá y putumayo del meta y del cauca
que estuvimos allá y que mayores
sabedores estuvieran en la búsqueda creo
que fue integral para poder
dar con este resultado final y nos
podría dar algún ejemplo para nosotros
que somos de ciudad y que pues no
entendemos la selva de estos
conocimientos uno es que se hace ritual
si hace un ritual para pedir permiso a
la selva y tú te proteges con chimuchimo
es una una planta es una medicina que
usan en la orinoquía
el mambe y el ambil que es originario de
las selvas amazónicas se utilizó esa
parte se se dio se compartió con el
ejército con las fuerzas militares se
hicieron rituales de sanación rituales
de fortaleza
uno al grupo que estábamos pero también
se hizo una gran minga o una gran
en cita a todos los abuelos ancestrales
de todos los pueblos para que ayudaran
en rituales en diferentes ceremonias en
partes del país para darle fuerza a
estos niños Y cómo fue precisamente como
la vivió usted está colaboración inédita
entre los pueblos indígenas y el
ejército colombiano creo que fue muy
simbólico
he oído gritar Guardia Guardia fuerza
fuerza por parte de un comandante de las
fuerzas militares eso es muy importante
porque resume de que de que se juntan
dos conocimientos un conocimiento
organizativo un conocimiento ancestral
de los pueblos indígenas con un
conocimiento tecnológico
estratégico de las fuerzas militares
este juntar nos hace llevar a resultados
y fueron se fue muy respetuoso en ese
diálogo de saberes ese diálogo de
saberes para lograr un objetivo creo que
da un mensaje muy bonito para el mundo y
para Colombia de que de que podemos
juntarnos podemos juntar ese
conocimiento no se no se trasponen a
veces se dice que el conocimiento
occidental o el conocimiento tradicional
se transpone se choca no son dos
ciencias que se complementan para
defender la vida lo vemos en un en este
ejemplo no en este ejemplo neurociencias
dos conocimientos dos saberes dos
palabras dos fuerzas que se juntan para
defender y proteger la vida y por otro
lado precisamente
como como mencionaba usted no está
condición este conocimiento indígena de
los menores les ha ayudado a sobrevivir
Pero por otro lado hay muchos análisis
que han señalado que refleja la
situación de estos niños la el olvido la
precariedad en la que viven a muchas
infancias indígenas en este país cómo lo
ve usted creo que
el traslado el poner en estos momentos
gracias a estos niños de poner la
atención en los niños en esa zona
hace poco se asesinaron niños indígenas
que fueron reclutados por el por la por
la disidencias entonces llamamos la
atención sobre la situación de los niños
en Colombia todos los niños están en
riesgo y cómo debemos protegerlos y
brindarles principal atención a partir
de sus de sus de sus realidades y es una
realidad que que vive Colombia de del
maltrato del sufrimiento que sobre
muchos niños y creo que Leslie pone
estos cuatro niños pone Oye poneros
atención pero la que llama esa atención
es la selva la que llama la atención es
la madre tierra es decir hay que poner
atención a los niños en Colombia en el
mundo porque ellos son la semilla ellos
son el continuar como hemos dicho
y le preguntó precisamente por el futuro
a corto y a medio plazo de estos menores
el presidente ha dicho que les va a
garantizar
acceso a la educación y se les van a
restablecer los derechos pero que más se
sabe exactamente Yo creo que es muy
importante que estos niños sigan su
camino sigan con toda la ayuda y que va
a brindar el gobierno que brinda las
instituciones pero que también no se
desenfoque desde sus principios como
pueblos indígenas o sea que hay esa
educación y que esa acompañamiento vaya
en concordancia con las organizaciones
indígenas con los pueblos indígenas y
con las comunidades indígenas que sea el
resultado de este encontrar para para
resolver los problemas y que vaya mucho
más allá deben crearse políticas
públicas de atención a niños indígenas
mucho más fuertes en esta política del
cuidado que se está planteando en el
Ministerio de la igualdad de cómo se
atiende la política del cuidado a
menores creo que se debe proyectar
porque Leslie manda un mensaje no solo
para ella sino para la protección de
todos los niños en Colombia exactamente
y precisamente hablando de protección de
la infancia a usted le ha molestado está
sobreexposición de estos Menores en los
medios de comunicación en la que
evidentemente se mezcla una cuestión de
interés público no pero las fotos han
sido muy compartidas no han sido
difuminadas las caras en muchas
ocasiones han habido primeros planos en
a grandes medios creo que allí está el
papel de Cómo se protege
en la cuestión de la comunicación ahí
parece que hay que llegar a los puntos
más exactos No porque las figuras a
veces las figuras
pueden pueden hacer más daño no cierto
Entonces cómo se protege a los niños
hasta desde el punto de vista visual
desde el punto de vista comunicativo
porque en últimas lo que queremos no es
la foto perfecta lo que queremos es
solucionar los problemas y solucionar
detrás de esto hay una historia detrás
de esto hay unas situaciones complejas
que han vivido los niños en sus familias
en las realidades que viven los pueblos
indígenas y creo que en eso hay que ser
bastante Un poco prudentes para la
protección porque digo en últimas los
protagonistas son estos niños Y como
protagonistas merecen protección y
cuidado y Luis eh rápidamente le
pregunto En qué otros ámbitos o en qué
le gustaría que en el futuro la guardia
indígena colaborara con las
instituciones colombianas para afrontar
estos retos de los que usted nos habla
yo lo que creo Es que la guardia
indígena es una institución propia de
los pueblos oficial porque nosotros
somos oficiales y que se dé en los
procesos se debe tener en cuenta porque
Hemos cumplido hemos no haber sido la
primer búsqueda que hemos tenido y cómo
coordinar Y cómo fortalecer esta Guardia
indígena a nivel institucional en en en
en fortalecerla y reconocer la como tal
es importante Para futuras situaciones
que se puedan presentar Luis Acosta pues
muchísimas gracias por haber compartido
su tiempo su análisis su conocimiento
aquí con nosotros en ram34 Gracias a
ustedes por escucharme y por por
compartir y dar a conocer el mundo esta
alegría que tengo en mi corazón y en mi
ser y ustedes hacemos una breve pausa
pero enseguida volvemos aquí en directo
América
[Música]